[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
the mail on Sunday leads with the
Phillip Schofield Scandal saying it has
an exclusive investigation and that
staff fear for the future of this
morning
the star leads with the statement by
schofield's former co-host Holly
Willoughby which she alleged he directly
lied to her about an inappropriate
relationship with a young colleague
it's the same story for the sun on
Sunday their headline Holly Phil lied to
me
the Sunday people claimed that ITV
intends to ax the program all together
the Sunday Telegraph reports that
Downing Street plans to ask retailers to
cap the price of basic food items
The Observer understands the government
could be just days away from suing to
prevent the release to the covert
inquiry of sensitive messages from the
likes of Boris Johnson and Rishi sunak
the Sunday Express hears from the Home
Secretary swella bravaman who insists we
can cut migration and thrive
and the boss at one of the princess of
wales's Charities is a convicted
murderer according to the Sunday Mirror
there's no suggestion however that her
Royal Highness was aware of that fact
and remind her that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Christina Patterson and Jake Wallace
Simons welcome to you both let's start
with this story on the front page of the
observer in which ministers we read have
just days to decide whether to take
steps to launch legal action against the
the covert inquiry and this is to keep
Bert's Secret at
a lot of sensitive messages and Senior
figures such as Boris Johnson and Rishi
sunak Jake
you know you can you can see why
ministers are worried about it after
lockdown files for the telegraph
published a few months ago revealed
swathes of WhatsApp messages from Matt
Hancock and other uh colleagues which
were hugely embarrassing about Hancock
showing him to be uh apparently uncon
you know not taking his job seriously
preening uh concern with their own
political political career uh ambulating
the public rather than working in their
best interests at times so you can see
while the ministers might be afraid they
might do the same treatment if they were
to disclose their WhatsApp messages to
the inquiry and thinking of taking legal
action however it seems to me and I
think to probably most people watching
that we need to know the global inquiry
which starts in a couple of weeks uh is
supposed to be looking at a wide range
of evidence ranging back 13 years taking
evidence from David Cameron and George
Osborne to see what happened in terms of
Britain's pandemic preparedness before
in the years before the covert pandemic
struck and working out whether austerity
affected it how he could have been
better prepared and then what happened
Blow by blow through the pandemic as
well and this is something that we all
are still living with the effects of the
pandemic we will be for a long long time
ourselves and our children and we really
need to know what went right and more
importantly what went wrong so that when
the next pandemic happens because I
suppose it will we can improve the
government's response towards it yes we
read that the Observer understands that
the government is standing firm in its
refusal to divulge the material
um it's not a good look is it uh
Christina seemingly hiding in
information
no it isn't
agree with everything Jake just said I
can absolutely see why they are nervous
and a lot of this revolves around the
status of WhatsApp message is because
the argument they would make I assume is
that WhatsApp is a kind of Chatty medium
where people it's the equivalent to
people having a chat at the water cooler
or you know over a cup of coffee which
of course I was going to say which
people were able to do less during the
pandemic but as we know they were
roaring away as usual at Downing Street
and in all those government offices uh
throwing parties at the same time so
actually they weren't uh they weren't
restricted to Whatsapp but I also agree
with Jake that this is too important
to restrict and I'm sure that Heather
Hallett the very very eminent judge who
is chairing the inquiry has not made
this decision likely this is for history
it's for the people who lost relatives
during the pandemic of which there were
I think 150 200 000 I've even lost I
think they stopped counting some time
ago so I don't know what the final
figure was but it this was a really
momentous event in the history of our
nation I can't also obviously of the
world but many people paid a very heavy
price and clearly some of the people
involved in the covert inquiry feel that
they paid a price that should not have
been paid had things been handled better
so I think it's important for history to
have that record and it's important for
Heather Hallett to be able to reach a
judgment on uh the balance of how much
care was taken and I think in future
probably government departments will
just have to be more careful about their
WhatsApp
um communication and treat it more like
email yes the first public hearings uh
just over two weeks away of that inquiry
let's turn to the Express and the
headline there we can cut migration and
Thrive these are the words of the Home
Secretary so Ella bravaman Jake
that's right so this is the Fallout from
the uh immigration figures which came
out on Thursday uh the Tory suggested
that it was going to be 700 000 up to a
million in actual facts it was 606 000
uh net migration which means that we
were six hundred thousand people uh more
uh population was 600 people 600 000
people bigger uh last year than it was
uh the year before uh and the the Tory
Wright is really has really got its
knives out now wanting to uh come at
Richard sunac and persuade him to do
what he can to bring those numbers down
and of course you know generally the
Tory base particularly in the north
we're very very keen to see that happen
and swella brothman is sounding a note
of reassurance saying that Britain can
bring the numbers down while still
maintaining a strong economy and growth
you know the problem is that our economy
over the last few decades has been
designed to rely upon migration
um we're allowing people who uh have
been born in Britain to leave the
workforce you've got more than five
million people now on benefits of
different sorts not in the workforce
even though we've got a million
vacancies and the economy has been
designed in such a way that those gaps
can be filled with foreign migrant
migrant workers as it were
um the the bar for entering this country
is very low to encourage large numbers
coming in and you know 600 000 is the
size of our third biggest city Glasgow
that's a Glasgow has come to Britain
over the last year that's a lot of
people and you know the the polling has
showed in Britain the people are not
anti-forigner they're not xenophobic
they're not anti-immigration but they
are concerned about the numbers the
uncontrolled numbers but the challenge
is going to be reforming the economy so
that it will it will be weaned off a
supply of foreign workers and begin to
get our workers back into the workforce
and trained up properly yes and read
that senior Tori is urging the prime
minister to show uh in quotations vision
and courage to overcome fears that the
economy will crash if he stops importing
cheap foreign labor Christina
when it snow rhetoric from swella
breatherman and all of this as we know
is essentially part of her ongoing
leadership bid I think the the top her
top priority is very clearly to make
herself leader of the Tory party and
ideally prime minister and she hasn't
said that actually she hasn't actually
said well she she did she did stand for
the leadership and uh was quite swiftly
cast out um and it's absolutely evident
that she's on maneuvers this is a power
grab for her she thinks that by
appealing to the right of the party then
that will gain increase her popularity I
think what she's miscalculated is that
the country is not where is not where
the right wing of the Tory party is the
country is currently much more concerned
about the economy than anything else and
the reason that there was
um a bit of a contra time with Jeremy
Hunt apparently suelo braveman chased
him down a corridor it has the
parliament this week wanting to upgrade
him for not being more in favor of
curbing migration but he understands
that at the moment because we haven't or
not we because the government did not
make preparations post-brexit to
rebalance the workforce and hasn't been
uh getting people trained up
um to take on the jobs that well I mean
because Brits don't want to do the jobs
that EU workers have left
um awakened then we are having to search
other parts of the world
um India Africa to import people to work
in Social care and so on so this our
economy would suffer if uh migration
were curbed now I happen to agree that
it is better to get British workers to
do this it doesn't make sense to British
workers not working and um and having
migrants coming in who need housing and
so on built especially you know where
there isn't enough accommodation for
them but you can't force people to work
if they don't want to do the work they
don't want to do the work and the people
who are currently not working that Jake
has referred to are not the same people
who work in Social care or Hospitality
but it's not entirely clear who those
people are but many of them were in
middle class jobs who perhaps got long
covered or decided not to decided to
retire early after the pandemic they're
not people who are going to be doing you
know kind of harvesting asparagus or
picking fruit and you can't just I mean
we would I don't suppose any of us would
be willing to go and pick fruit so I
don't think it's right for politicians
like Zoella Bradman on her very high
salary to say that Brits should be doing
this kind of work it's generally very
poorly paid work and the people who want
to do it are migrants well we know for a
while that the conservatives have
criticized the labor party for not
having ideas not coming up with ideas in
this arena in the Sunday Telegraph labor
are giving forth their ideas suggesting
that they'd curb immigration by putting
time limits on how long companies are
able to import foreign workers in those
shortage occupation so they're putting
their stall out
in the papers tomorrow Jake
that's right it's interesting that labor
is also seeking to deliver some tough
rhetoric on immigration
um they're picking up as a Tories are
that people are concerned about it uh
and do want it to stop you know the 45
000 people that came in on small boats
last year roughly the population of
Andover
um are not included in the migration
figures 606 000 uh and but really it's a
small boats issue that's been capturing
people's concerns leading to pressure on
overall migration figures and laborers
suggesting that they can put a time
limit on the amount of time that uh that
specific jobs are on the shortage list
therefore eligible for immigrants to
come in and fill those jobs and the hope
is that will encourage employers to trim
up a British Workforce and offer maybe
higher pay as an incentive to bring them
back into the workforce and do the jobs
that otherwise we've built by by Foreign
workers uh let's just fit this last one
in before the we break Christina and
this is um also in the telegraphs in our
stores to cap basic food prices um tell
us about this story
yes well this is a very untory idea and
apparently it's nicked from the French
who um have been introducing price caps
in into supermarkets to try to
um
control or at least have some effect on
the soaring food prices that are
affecting people around the world but
particularly in the UK because our
inflation is higher than than most in
Europe and it's about I think about
double uh the inflation in the US at the
moment
and the idea is that for example milk
might be kept at a particular price
I'm personally not opposed but actually
the profit margins for supermarkets are
really very low and what I wouldn't want
to see is Farmers and suppliers paying
the price because the profit margins on
products like milk are currently so low
that sometimes farmers are supplying
them at a loss they are still having to
pay hugely increased costs um through
increases in fuel prices uh General
inflation recasts and and many are
barely scraping even in fact many are
operating at a loss so I mean my first
preference would actually be to attack
the energy companies I know we have a
price cap but actually to put for
example windfall taxes on the energy
companies because those are the profits
of war the reason the energy companies
have made such vast profits are because
of the war in Ukraine in a situation
with
um energy from from Russia and I think
to attack the supermarkets who are not
who generally supply stuff with a very
low profit margin is is slightly unfair
Christine a very interesting point that
you make those um further down in the
chain the repercussions for them
um we are going to leave it there and
take a break stay right where you are
coming up will this morning survive the
next few mornings and should it discuss
that next
foreign
[Music]
there they are
um right on time we're gonna have a look
at this story which is across many of
the the newspapers and this is the um
let's go filled story who's now left ITV
uh the star their headline
um really the first time Holly
willoughby's actually gone on record
saying that uh she's so hurt that Philip
Schofield actually lied to her
Christina
yeah I mean and I have to admit I I
haven't watched this morning and um I
not you know I I I've been following the
story but I can't say that it it's kind
of top of my priorities at the moment
but I do think that I completely
understand why she would feel betrayed
and I think that for him to have
basically pretended to be her best
friend and have had this close sort of
on sofa but also off air friendship and
then discover I mean any of us who've
had a friend who we discover has lied to
us or had an affair that they have not
talked about
um particularly in this situation it
appears to have been an affair with a
very young uh employee colleague and
that would be extremely you know putting
aside the ethics of that and the power
relationship and whether it's
appropriate to have a relationship with
a teenage person in the workplace to
whom you are you know very much the boss
putting all of that aside I think for
Holly Willoughby she must feel
absolutely as if the whole thing has
been a sham between them so I can see
that she would be very upset and I think
the repercussions for ITV and for the
management at ITV and and quite possibly
for the show are enormous I think I can
see why the show would now be in the
balance I can see that the brand has
been contaminated and they may well feel
that they have to exit
and Jake what are your thoughts on how
the the papers have been covering the
story because it's it is everywhere and
it's all over uh the papers there is
genuine interest in this
yeah I I I guess I the way I see it is
that it's important to clarify what
we're talking about I mean nobody's
talking about anything illegal
um if that were the case then scurfield
would be under investigation and and
arrested and all the rest of it uh and
that obviously would be really
devastating and wrong and a serious
course for concern if it's not that then
what is it it's it's a it's a moral
issue it's a question of perhaps a
senior employee uh abusing his power
over over a younger a younger man in in
this case and that seems to me to be a
disciplinary matter for ITV an internal
matter
um not necessarily A matter for the
public it seems to me to be A Private
Matter between between Phillips
Schofield and his employers
um it seems that I mean if he was a
public elected representative if he was
prime minister and his judgment affected
uh all of our standards of living and
and the future of our country then yes
would be interested in his judgment and
his moral character but he's not the TV
presenter so it seems to me as if um the
story is a little bit uh overhyped and
Christina just uh very quickly do you do
you think that it it does have
implications for the entire uh show for
the whole of this morning that this
might be the the end of this morning
well I think it might do because I think
it leaves such a sour taste I think that
the whole stick of the show was two you
know very nice kind of uh down to earth
people with a very genuine honest rep or
um speaking every morning to the nation
and that Kelly has not been that the
reality of the Christina
sorry we are out of time thank you both